ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon soir
bon ben on y va et musique
alors
attendez attendez je peux pas travailler
en étant emprisonnés comme ça attendant
laissez moi et c'est moins libre at home
et mouvement s'il vous plaît je voudrais
qu'on me libère merci merci alors
d'abord il faudrait un petit peu de
lumière pour éclairer cette nappe via
magnifique ans que c'est plus grand
risque de céder et puis disons
évidemment tous sont en bas vous
entendez bien en bas du son vers le old
trafford en eau tout le monde entend ok
parfait la musique elle condamnait de
musique mais où ian ella doba de portée
et puis un cadre bon il me faut un cadre
évidemment
gare au gorille a pas d'image il n'y a
pas de cérémonie et puis les crs que
tous les césar sont là j'ai le petit
qu'un meilleur acteur meilleure actrice
meilleur film hu et le public est ce
qu'il est là
justin public et on peut y aller et son
parti
[Musique]
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]